صباح الخير لورين كريستين ،
مصادر متعددة أخبرتني أن تقرير
مدير المخابرات الوطنية
متوقع في وقت مبكر من يوم الخميس كنا
ننتظر هذا التقرير لفترة طويلة
وقد تم
تمريره فعليًا إلى قانون في عام 2019 لكن إدارة ترامب
اختارت بعد ذلك  تجاهله ، إنه تقرير غير سري
صادر عن مكتب مدير
المخابرات الوطنية وهو مطلوب
لتوضيح
ما وجده مجتمع المخابرات
حول ما
يعرفه المسؤولون السعوديون وما فعلوه الآن في عام 2018
بعد مقتل خاشقجي ، قيمت المخابرات المركزية
بثقة عالية أن  أمر
ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان نفسه
بالقتل الوحشي لخاشقجي ،
الأمير بالطبع
ينفي ذلك لأننا نتعلم عن
رابط آخر بين
MBs كما هو معروف وقتل
خاشقجي في اسطنبول ، حصلنا على
وثائق من قضية محكمة كندية
كشفت عنها.  أن الطائرتين النفاثتين الخاصتين
اللتين حملتا فريق الضرب السعودي
كانتا تديرهما شركة
ولي العهد
قبل أقل من عام من
جريمة القتل الأشيب ، كان قد
أمر بتحويل شركة الطيران هذه
إلى صندوق الاستثمار في البلاد
الذي
يتحكم فيه.  قال إنه
يُظهر خطًا
مباشرًا لقتل جمال خاشقجي ، لقد طلبنا من المسؤولين السعوديين
ردًا
ولم نحصل على أحد ، بينما قال
الرئيس جو بايدن إنه
قرأ التقرير الذي رفعت عنه السرية ، ولم يقدم
أي تفاصيل
قالها للتو إنه سيفعل  التحدث
مع الملك السعودي سلمان
قريبًا وهو ما لم يفعله بعد ،
وهو أمر ملحوظ لأنه في
منصبه
لأكثر من شهر